Well
hello, how are you? Natale Lancelot greets you
and with your brief news now
in Spanish, relatives of the student
I saw who died during a
boxing fight are preparing for his
funeral. Nate in Valencia, 20 years old,
was unconscious in a fight and  he died
once in the hospital both the
university and the local
authorities are still investigating his death
the funeral in valència will be on sunday
december 19 at the
holy spirit catholic church a year has passed since the accident
in which five cyclists died
due to a  intoxicated driver
near searchlight on saturday morning
several bicyclists will gather for a
ride in honor of the victims it will begin
in the parking lot of the church
located on the wine near the intersection
with las vegas boulevard the group will be
ready at 6 45 for  start the
bike ride at 7 on las vegas
boulevard
in the school district that's how it is from
the year 2022 a new law will come into effect
In force, which changes the implemented date
for students to start kindergarten,
children will have to be 5 years
old by the first day of the
school year, which begins on August 8.
Previously, the school district gave
a little tolerance by letting them
enroll if they met the  5 prior to
September 30, however for next year
now they will have to
be 5 to register if you
need to know more details about this
new rule you can visit
the section in Spanish and not snap dotcom or
enter our social networks
news 8 nn  and now we turn to
the weather forecast today we will enjoy
a sunny day with temperatures
around 50 degrees it is however they will drop
for the night and there is a cold alert
for most of the county train the
nights will be cold especially on the
weekend it is recommended to cover
plants outdoors and any
outdoor pipe there are chances of
drizzle again for the  next week
beautiful day greets you even
lanzelotti and this was your brief
informative of and no snap in Spanish